thank you
is
right
um
foreign
[Music]
so
thank you
what
thank you
[Music]
uh
so
so
look
so
uh
so
[Music]
so
great
hmm
so
so
nicely
thank you
[Music]
so
so
what's up
[Music]
policy
i mean
is
yeah this morning
foreign
is
you're like
that takes good
the outcome
i guess
i'm sure
[Music]
[Music]
um
okay
um
[Applause]
the house
um
that's that's that's um
[Laughter]
what's going on the only good thing
about this crappy rotation is that i get
to see you more often
it really has been forever i know we've
been way too long
oh really yeah
all right so
um don't worry
uh
until it drives
oh yeah because people love women right
now
[Laughter]
um
20. hello hello hello okay
we're running behind guys what a
surprise
hey yeah
[Music]
oh
um
[Music]
i'm not oh
thank you
oh
accurately
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah yeah i mean
possible
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
oh
let me talk about china
oh
jason is that live no did someone
clipped it
you have to pay attention
[Music]
um
yes
now
[Music]
but it was like
[Music]
um
and
but you know
i've never heard
failed
[Music]
fixed the issue it was um you know as
you know we've got several devices and
so it sort of there's a lot of your
points
um the issue was what we thought along
this time was with our streaming
software and actually wasn't worth
setting zoom
on where to bring the audio um
it was useful it was a really simple
change but it was sort of
counterintuitive
and we now have documented on
no no
um
[Music]
a little different
[Music]
one day
i think 19 months
okay
our first
nope never did but i think
that and i think we'll do it with her i
think that he understood the sensation
was different
oh okay and so it made a cut there was a
confidence
versus just sort of then again that
might be overseas
um but literally because
yeah and then
[Music]
um
exactly by yourself 20 minutes ew
what's most important
really yeah
he's not and what he is she's not
she's probably more attuned to him than
her
that's probably typical for a second one
she loves you know she played
two minutes
thursday friday
no i'm not giving it up
it's a load
[Laughter]
what have you come to any terms yet i
think you just understood my question to
be awesome
so i gotta come back to him
well yes again i go back okay
good afternoon sorry for keeping me
waiting a little longer
hope you're all well yesterday we see
we received welcome news that there was
an arrest made in the shooting earlier
this month
the two la county sheriffs it was so
disgusting
just a targeted attack i know that
sheriffs have a long road to recovery
ahead of them but i hope this brings a
sense of peace to them and to their
families
our police officers take on immense risk
every single day
and they should know that the majority
of the country is praying for them
and for their safety today marks the
71st
anniversary of the people's republic of
china
over the decades we have seen a
communist regime
who have been ruthless in their attempt
to seize power
today's chinese communist party is no
closer to allowing their citizens to
have freedom
than they were 31 years ago in tenement
square
we have seen them break international
agreements carry out human
rights abuses and violate the
sovereignty of neighboring
nations previous administrations have
implemented a strategy
of accommodation let's just look at what
has happened
former president obama in 2011 let me
quote him i absolutely believe that
china's peaceful rise
is good for the world and it's good for
america
vice president joe biden just a few
years ago in 2015 stated
we want to see china rise as joe biden
who is the democratic party changed his
view
well just last year as he was running
for president joe biden said
china is not competition for us
it's an interesting quote that he would
make perhaps democrats are comfortable
with bending
to a knee for china but republicans will
not gamble with our economy
or our national security that is why
house republicans
stood up a china task force back in may
the china task force was actually
supposed to be bipartisan
i went to speaker pelosi more than a
year ago
talked to the democratic leadership for
more than eight months finally got them
to agree
we even had to negotiate on the numbers
same number of republicans as democrats
because this transcends party the
challenge of what
china gives not only to the world to
america
pre-coveted and we got to the date where
we were going to announce it in a joint
press conference
even the washington post reporter had
already written up a story
only for the democrats to back away
over the past few months the members of
the task force worked to draft a
comprehensive blueprint
to counter china's threat and yesterday
they delivered
they continue to follow through on our
commitment to america
we laid out earlier this month to
rebuild the greatest economy
we have ever seen and to end our
dependency on china and implement
pro-growth policies
much like democrats have neglected to
protect america from geopolitical
threats
they are also neglecting their
livelihoods at home for the past several
months there has been one common
denominator
stopping us from getting another coveted
relief bill
it's the speaker of the house but let's
listen to what she has done
we know from past behavior every time
the four leaders got together to do a
coveted relief bill
we came to an agreement after speaker
pelosi had delayed it
sometimes a week at a time with much
needed money for small businesses for
their employees
to stay open or to keep paying them it
was so
popular that we're going to run out of
money that the speaker was warned about
it weeks in advance
she proudly stood at night late night
television in front of a refrigerator
eating ice cream
almost laughing at the american public
by saying she said no
she told us she would keep us in not let
us leave in august because she has the
power to do that the only one
but she let us all go instead of
utilizing that pressure
to make people come to a common
agreement but she did call us back
i was kind of excited when i heard she
was going to but was it for coveted
relief was it to deal with those who are
unemployed or the small businesses that
were going to shut their doors and lay
more people off
or maybe it was for the schools that
needed the resources
to open back up no
it was purely political once again it's
about a post office that already had
money
post office that we know does not have
the challenge with delivering the mail
it's the states
they do not have the ability to handle
within the election office
all the mail ballots
so she said once again she would not let
us leave
i wonder if we could trust read her word
this time
it's interesting she decided only once
republicans have put on the floor
discharge petition
which the american public so they could
understand it's one of those archaic
rules
within the house it's the only power the
minority has to get a bill to the floor
to go around the speakers to get 218
people to sign
you would think it'd be quite easy to
get 218 members
to sign a discharge petition to help
small businesses they've already voted
for it once before
why deny it to go forward
some within our own party has criticized
her so you know what we did yesterday on
a vote
we actually put it to the floor and
every single democrat voted against it
so it seems nancy pelosi has as much
power on her members as the chinese
communist party has on their whole party
when i look at what her compromise bill
is all about
well it once again mentions cannabis
more than it mentions jobs
which i don't think those in covet
relief
believe that's the priority they should
do provides a massive tax break to the
wealthy
and you know who would get the biggest
tax break of all michael bloomberg
i guess that's okay in the democratic
party because he's supplied the most
money for him
100 million i guess in florida he talked
in his own debate
that he bought congress as majority with
more than 100 million dollars
he sent him 60 million now so i guess
they feel obligated to give him the
biggest tax break
of almost any american
you know one thing it does cut back on
money
to make our streets safe and secure 600
million dollars they cut from their
original bill
for law enforcement
if joe kennedy is i mean if joe biden is
the democratic party
and they're cutting 600 million
i guess he does support cutting the
police and defunding them
nancy pelosi has said numerous times
that
she would keep us here to get it done
that was in july
she made us wait all summer but who did
she really make way
the small businesses that have now
declared bankruptcy
or those people that are employed by
them that are now out of work
are those at their unemployment that do
not get the extra benefit
or what about the airlines
could she not see past politics for once
could she not close the refrigerator and
listen to the american public
could she not think that she's above the
law that only she can go
to get her hair done while others are
denied
the arrogance is appalling and it must
stop
with everything that was happening from
the presidential debate
to the lack of action in the house
i'm afraid too many people missed some
critical information
i want to commend director radcliffe
on bringing transparency to the
intelligence
if you read his letter
everybody in america should read this
letter every single member in
congress should not only read this
letter in the house or senate
but we need the underlying information
behind it
that we've been asking for more than
four years that the nightmare that
america was put through
if what is stated in here is correct
is unbelievable that's why facts need to
be known
it's not about politics it's about the
democracy
of our nation this is probably the
biggest news
that has happened
i commend director radcliffe for
bringing transparency out but more
importantly
i ask that the members in the house and
senate can get the underlying
information behind us
so we can get once and for all the truth
with that let me open up for questions
yes ma'am so um secretary mnuchin came
back to pelosi with a 1.6 trillion
dollar offer
uh yesterday um some of your own members
including kevin brady have brought up
concerns about those spending levels and
some provisions in that
um i was wondering if you shared any of
those concerns and if they are able to
come to a deal on something along those
lines
whether you think it's something it
shows how far the administration
republicans are going
where pelosi continues to put the
roadblock even higher
for the option of not having something
you've been here
this entire year you've watched the four
members all come to
four leaders when they all come together
we come to an agreement this is the only
time
that the speaker has tried to take all
the power and it's the only time
nothing is getting done her own members
of her own
party are writing letters to her
concerned
the only reason why she has any movement
is because republicans put up a
discharge petition
it's interesting why she let us go last
friday at the last minute when the
discharge petition became ripe so you'd
only have 15 minutes to sign it on
friday
it's interesting why they keep
democratic staff down by
the book to sign to look exactly who's
signing and what intimidation they're
making
to keep democrats holding back be
interesting to know for the american
public
why would anybody in congress not sign
it's not asking for more money it's
allowing the money that is there
for ppp to go to those employees who
need it
they're hurting but do they think
winning is so important to try to hurt
the economy further
because that's the decision she's making
it's a calculated decision
it's a harmful decision it is the wrong
decision
on that note if a deal is going to be at
least 1.6 trillion and
your members are concerned about that
price tag senate republicans are
concerned about going higher than 1
billion
if the deal is reached today or
potentially this week
can you guarantee that your members are
going to support that
you can't ever say what people on the
democrat side republican until you see
what's in it is there liability
protection
are the schools going to be protected
from being sued or the small businesses
because the democrats never propose that
is this just
more money into cannabis and not to jobs
i mean what is the priority of the
underlying
there are so many problems within the
democratic bills why it's gone nowhere
and why pelosi continues to hold on for
a false hope that nobody will support
she had 14 of her own party vote against
it i bet there would be further now
so the real question is what is inside
the ability to do it there is lots of
money still sitting out there that's
already appropriated
almost a trillion dollars or more that
we can get
to the american public to the states to
the schools
to the unemployed but it's only been
held up because of nancy pelosi
yes question just to clarify do you
support the 1.6 trillion dollar offer
that i have
i haven't seen it all yet okay um i want
to ask about the debate
um and specifically would you have any
advice for the president going forward
in the next debate
is there anything you think he should do
differently do you think the attacks on
joe biden sons for example was a bridge
too far i mean what what
is your advice to the president there
about how he should tackle this next
debate
first if you ask me about the debate
president trump won the debate
could it be more productive actually my
best advice is
let joe biden talk he is the democratic
party
his ideas are far long gone
i think the more he talks the more the
american public would decide
they don't want joe biden is there a
reason why he puts a lid
on almost most of his days is there a
reason why he is hid
hidden and not communicated is there a
reason why he won't tell the american
public
who he'd point to the supreme court
justice
candidate trump did that before the last
election
so the public knew ahead of time
do you think it was a mistake not just
letting you speak more and
letting the public know it's a mistake
or not but i'd let him speak all he
wants
every time joe biden and maybe that's
why the campaign puts a lid on it about
every
what they do in the two weeks prior half
of all the days would put a lid on by 10
a.m
joe biden usually gets in trouble not by
somebody asking a question but just by
he's talking
so the more he talks i think the
stronger president trump's campaign is
then just run on the facts run on the
record
you know joe biden has a long record 47
years
inside the senate put that in
perspective
when joe biden went to the senate there
were people in the senate who were born
in the 1800s
think of all the things joe biden won't
tell you
why won't he why won't he name one law
enforcement officer
who would endorse him why wouldn't he
tell the american public more
about his son when he was vice president
why did you bring your son on a
government airplane
to china why did your son do business
with china
what were you warned by those in the
administration about what your son was
doing
now with new information coming forward
that a person very close to putin a wife
provided more than
and a half million dollars to your son
instead of just saying no what you want
the information
when you want to come forward doesn't
the public have a right to know
but more importantly what are your
policies because you say one thing
during the primary now you're saying
something different
i've never seen anybody flip-flop more i
watched him look a woman in the eye
said read my lips to the point of what
he would say
that he was going to end fossil fuel
then he wants to try to say he's for
fracking after he said he was opposed to
it
he says he's for a green new deal but
when it's a debate no it's not a green
new deal
but it still does the same effect to the
economy
of harming it he says he's going to
raise taxes on the very first day
he also said some very damaging things
as well
he also said he thinks poor people are
just as smart as white people
our white kids i think to be exact
that's offensive
he also stood as vice president went to
a former kkk's
funeral speaking very highly of him
along with speaker pelosi so yes
i would let joe biden talk more and if i
was president trump
just say what you have done the
strongest economy
in the history of the nation you compare
directly across
from the failures of the joe biden obama
administration
you reformed the va
where hundreds of thousands were harmed
and died
because of lackability even to get an
appointment
you rebuilt the military
there is record after record
which president trump has to run on and
i think it's his strongest
ability to win a re-election yes
what are the chances you think the house
of representatives could decide an
election speaker pelosi put out a
note saying that it was important for
her to win state races because right now
republicans control more
house more like the chambers of congress
and these states and
chambers in the states and stuff so do
you think that
it could get to the house of
representatives to decide and should
there be an
emphasis on winning these state houses
and state elections
i'm not quite sure why you want to win
the state houses maybe i don't unders
understand it correctly it's one percent
she was explaining earlier this morning
that it was it could go at one point
to where each state gets one vote so
california 53
you know but that's not a state house
a state house legislative bodies in
sacramento the 53 members
who represent california is a federal
office in congress
so i understand she she's talking about
a state house but that's a whole
different subject
the way the rules read in the
constitution
it comes to the house only if it's a tie
which is a
which is really hard to do but maybe
it's possible
it's probably more possible back in 1980
because there was a third-party
candidate i don't see a third-party
council who's voting for one or the
other so probably pretty difficult to
get a tie but if it comes to the house
each state gets one vote so the makeup
so you have some states that only have
one representative alaska
south dakota north dakota montana and
then if you
look at like the number of parties by
the number of states republicans have
more states than democrats even though
we're in the minority
but it takes 26 ever to get the nominee
to become president and the senate picks
the vice president there's also a factor
in there if it can't get to that point
the speaker could become president but
they'd have to resign that position as
well
and i know she has such hatred for this
president
that she tries to find every avenue but
i'm not quite sure she understands
the ramification of how it works but i
think it's very
not very likely that it does come to the
house
the letter that you had mentioned from
director radcliffe the timing right
before the first debate
the senate the bipartisan republican led
intelligence committee
dismissed that early on uh they called
it was
russian state the consortium reporting
from sources on the committee said that
it was
they didn't have this information
what i would like you to do is go to any
member
the intel committee the house the senate
i have to be a member of gang of eight i
never do any of this
this is why this is so important don't
bring into timing
if you want to bring into timing read in
this letter
when this stuff was transpiring let's
look here july 26 2016
september 2016. very interesting things
being said here on that timing
people have been requesting this
information and underlying information
for the last four years because they've
been investigating this
the real question would lie is who's
been holding this information up
from the members of congress and the
senate why did we put the american
public through so much
why is it just now we're getting this
information
radcliffe should be commended for
bringing out transparency
that's exactly what he said he would do
in the job and that's what he's doing
the question for anybody in the senate
or the house should be
i want to see the underlying info and
why were we denied that info
all this time
i asked devin nunes who was the chair of
the intel
had he seen this information
should yeah it's his birthday today too
so we should wish him happy birthday to
talk to him
what do you think the chances are of a
five-person deal coming together on
coronavirus
at this point what's nancy pelosi still
involved she has thought i'd give you a
low number
if you put the four leaders in the room
or if you put a few other
people from the democratic party we'd
get one today
what about meadows do you think he
increases decreases those chances
i think about it meadows was
[Music]
yeah when we did one of the bills he was
already chief
he helped in it um speaker pelosi
you've been here you've reported it do
you remember that sunday that we all
came back
the four leaders do you remember what
schumer said just the day before
like the deal was done we sat in the
room and
nancy blew it up for a week really not
changing the deal but giving more money
for the arts
then you remembered after we got the ppp
her stopping more money for it
it wasn't asking for any new legislation
was just put more money in because it's
so successful
saved more than 50 million jobs
the question has to go to the speaker
now
are you doing this for political reasons
do you want america to hurt so bad to
try to get some advantage in an election
or do you think that they're holding out
for a potential president biden do you
think that's the
strategy would that be what benefit how
many more people would be unemployed
the president from the very beginning
has been supportive of getting an
agreement
it's only been one person holding it up
so it's easy to realize everything about
her is politics
shianna maybe not get her hair done
all by herself but listen to the people
who've been unemployed
listen to the people who own that shop
who've been closed for so long who need
the ppp
listen to the people who need the
unemployment and if she wants to put a
red line then
go ask denny hoyer why he said that's
not a red line the republicans are
actually right about that
that all states are not equal so any
point that she makes
is really just a political point to stop
something instead of finding a reason
to put people before politics that's all
we're asking
so if speaker pelosi is not involved
we'd get it done
our own people know that as well you'll
have a nice weekend thanks have a good
one
okay